[Musique]
le mara ms 13 n'a pas coupé en trois morceaux
est un symbole qu'ils ont
puis détruisez le premier signe sauvage sur
maître roi au milieu du jeu la pâte
entendre un mélange d'où avec le
beau j'ai l'impression de ne pas remplir le
mission vous êtes touché par les 13 restants
secondes
c'est pourquoi ça s'appelle mois grandir parce que
être 13 secondes que j'ai un gramme
battre avec le feu avec des valeurs ya monde
a déjà dans la porte wiiware
le ms-13 est quand même très organisé
vend de la drogue dans les postes de guerre à
haillons et tue des gens
juan annonce de la mara salvatrucha et de la
réseau social de liaison
balle et peu d'où il devrait y avoir
compté quelques années que le message
pacificateur il y a neuf mois
[Musique]
et bien quand j'avais 15 pce
percevoir les taxes de guerre alors pour
ils les enverront dans une autre région pour être de
la terre a tout perdu au profit de la zone où
on vend de la drogue quand tu montes et
regardez qu'ils grandissent nous vous donnons
transmissions très fortes et vous faites
les missions qu'ils te tueraient
personnes
j'avais 18 ans
18 ans quand j'ai tué la première personne
dans des affaires personnelles avec une arme à feu
Je ne vais pas vraiment dire qu'il n'est pas venu
Je n'avais même pas une équipe sauvage, la vérité est que j'avais
comme trois fois la vérité que j'avais
on tue avec des pistolets d'un 9
millimètres et quelqu'un ici a dit que ça ne va pas si bien
quartier blanc le message sur place
Ciel parce que la vérité est que nous avons tué
nous pouvons dire à cette personne qu'ils se sont aimés
fuyez le gang ms votre numéro marteau
la nouvelle ville d'aguapey en équipe nous
tout le monde a un salaire pour van
eh bien, il gagnait presque 1 500 pesos par
semaine pour prendre soin du quartier peut jeter
quand ils t'ont envoyé tuer des gens
l'huile de nava est un privilège si
voulait de l'argent vêtements pour femmes
qu'ils te changeaient de pistolet
privilèges qui protègent abbas avec le
jardin et rangées aussi qu'artistiques
tuer la première personne si nerveuse
endroit fumeur avec beaucoup de réflexion
Que pourraient-ils faire? C'est tout à moi, pas ma mère.
IL
il faut tout faire
pour soi aussi parce que c'est déjà
coincé dans la famille et doit le faire
comme je dis tu dois faire quoi
ils disent
[Musique]
support dv de notre partie de mise à mort aussi
du roi des professeurs, je devrais faire quoi
que je me dis que tu ne peux pas le remplir je ne sais pas
si tu donnes un joyeux anniversaire avec punition
ils vous réchauffent la première fois si vous ne le faites pas
ils accomplissent ce qu'ils vous ont toujours frappé
13 secondes restantes
pour chaque coup si tous les trois par
ça s'appelle ms-13 parce qu'ils te donnent 13
secondes je demande déjà une raclée
le deuxième tissu comme battre l'hôte déjà
le troisième vas-y ils te tuent
salvatrucha et pilule mcconnell
possédant cette description existe est
acte de torture d'une victime de télévision
blanc l'homme au vent webmaster
roi témoin liens factices et delvin
l'atlantide inversée si l'on vit nous
ils se sont cassés en morceaux et les ont jetés dans
une bande de plasma la mara ms 13
ne pas couper en trois morceaux
C'est un symbole qu'ils ont déjà
amenez nous la personne puisque messieurs
ils ont commencé à extraire des informations et ayant
des informations qu'ils saisissent
parce qu'ils ont déjà coupé les gens un
peu j'ai seulement entendu les cris et
tout ce qui est moderne
afin qu'ils
ils croient que le mara est là
toujours dans tous les quartiers qui sont déjà
le gang le plus organisé de tout le honduras
amérique centrale mais je n'ai jamais essayé
tuer une personne devant la seule vérité
parce que la théorie de maman n'avait pas le
mot que je n'avais pas de bateau pour tuer quelqu'un
qu'est-ce qui te fait soulever parce que la vérité
qui a dit non j'ai regardé que ce n'était pas pour
ma
J'ai senti que s'ils me tuaient ou me touchaient
prison et maintenant parce que dans le quartier où
nous étions était très chaud plus que
tout devait être mon fils plus que tout
je l'ai fait pour lui
être capable de manœuvrer des gangs
parce que cette salière et dans celle de la vérité de
mon pays pour pouvoir s'en débarrasser
seule solution est
l'église
ou s'enfuir sont deux façons de s'en sortir
du gang mais ta vie à l'intérieur
le gang ne peut pas sortir
kóvacs llongueras et fin du mois à
wikileaks
et ils existent au honduras cela se comporte
avec une réduction même si vous allez à
gouvernement du honduras
Eh bien, ils ne vous aident pas parce que
le mauvais est comme je dis organiser
ils peuvent acheter les flics peuvent
acheter beaucoup de choses aux gens
les entrepreneurs et même les entrepreneurs ont
mort pour la même chose aussi
et même les policiers sont
la tradition n'intervient pas n'aide pas
envoyer des publicités est très difficile
si vous m'aidez à l'improviste
les gens retournent à diego
connais bien ma vie, la vérité est que
manque comme vécu face à
vivre sa vie travailler gagner sa vie
honnêtement ne dérangez personne sortez
allez-y et
et ne pas essayer de commettre la même chose
erreurs que j'ai faites avant ici
dire dans et des widgets sans fin sans fin
informer si je le regrette parce que j'ai tué
des gens que tu ne voulais vraiment pas
être mauvais parce que c'était pour survivre à un
survivre à quelqu'un dans la rue
drogues de gang je regrette
parce que parfois plus pour tout pour moi
famille civile et militaire et de créer une
Dieu
à peu près toute ma famille est chrétienne
réaliser que
Je leur pardonne un dieu pardonne tout
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
parfois je me sentais mal mal mal très mal
parfois mais si vous avez senti qu'ils ont
été avec moi et m'a aidé dans tous
les autres situations et a sauvé par
tous les chemins qu'ils ont pris aujourd'hui
et si la vérité est que
je l'aide vraiment
oh
[Musique]